What is PageSpeed Service and how does it
work?
Web pages today contain a lot more than HTML.
They combine stylesheets, images, videos,
Javascript files and other components to give
the rich interactive experience we now expect
on the web.
This means however that to display a web page,
a browser has to make several HTTP requests,
as many as 43 requests for the average web
page, to fetch all these resources from the
server hosting your site.
Many such network requests to fetch files
one after another increases wait time and
slows down the page.
Slow web pages can make visitors to your site
less engaged and even frustrated, leading
to lower conversion and lost revenue.
Google PageSpeed Service is an online service
you can use to automatically speed up your
website.
It rewrites web pages dynamically to apply
several performance-improving practices, and
then serves the optimized pages via Google
servers to reduce page load time.
When you first setup PageSpeed Service for
your site, you’ll be guided to change its
DNS entry so that your domain name points
to PageSpeed servers.
Once completed, PageSpeed servers will serve
your web pages and intelligently cache their
resources to serve them to users faster.
They’ll also fetch newer content from your
original host server so that the latest version
of your website is always served to users.
PageSpeed servers are located in Google operated
datacenters distributed around the world.
So your site will benefit from the speed,
efficiency and security of the same infrastructure
that powers all of Google.
PageSpeed rewriters use a combination of techniques
to optimize web pages.
One of them is to reduce the number and size
of the resources to be fetched.
PageSpeed Service rewrites web pages to merge
and compress Javascript, stylesheet and image
files, and to parallelize the download of
these files wherever possible.
This means fewer HTTP requests and lower round-trip
times, so your web page gets delivered to
the browser faster.
Another technique is to reduce the perceived
page load time.
This is the minimum time that users have to
wait before they can view the page.
The typical web page today is long and has
many visual elements.
But only a small portion of the page is initially
visible in the browser once the page has loaded.
PageSpeed Service can rewrite a web page so
that the parts of the page that users expect
to see first get downloaded first.
This means users can engage with your site
right away, without having to wait for the
full page to load.
The rewriters can also cache parts of the
page that don’t change frequently so they
get delivered to the browser quickly on future
visits to your site.
This combination of advanced rewriter technology
and global serving infrastructure can dramatically
reduce the load time of your web pages, often
by as much as 40%.
Faster web pages improve the experience of
visitors to your site and so can increase
both traffic and customer conversion.
So get started with PageSpeed Service today
and discover how fast your websites can be!